[Music]
now sign konichiwa hello everyone i'm
Yoshiaki Koizumi from Nintendo in this
Nintendo Direct for e3 2019 we'll
showcase a variety of games
many of them coming soon but before we
dig in to the next game there is someone
I'd like to introduce first what what
are you doing here wait wait wait wait
wait a minute there's been a bit of a
mix-up oh you're not the right Bowser
sorry but I'm the right Bowser for this
presentation not this way
no no this way bye-bye
maybe next time are you related no but
we'd get that a lot well let's get back
to it
please take it away
hi everyone I'm Doug Bowser from
Nintendo of America and I'm thrilled to
join you for today's Nintendo Direct
this is our chance to show the world we
have games for every type of player on
Nintendo's switch whether you love
action RPGs or you're just looking for
something new we've got you covered okay
so let's get a look at one of those
games by taking a tour of Luigi's
Mansion three
[Music]
Luigi's invited to a gorgeous hotel with
Mario peach and the others